but let's get to my first guest I am
very excited / really nervous
she is a true Hollywood legend a
children's book author and it just
absolutely all class she is a true lady
Dame Julie Andrews are you there I am
here and you're there I can see that you
are I'm very nervous and excited I have
one quick question because I actually
don't know this answer do you do I say
Dame every time or the personal thing
and it's just something that one keeps
kind of quietly to oneself some people
use it I don't everybody if I've ever
had to say Sir Elton John I always have
to say sir so I'm like I'm gonna get
this right so how are you because I mean
this whole Pinta mix happening are you
safe or you're healthy I am safe I am
healthy I am fully enough and I'm sure
you find the same thing
I feel busier than ever because one is
doing so much via the internet and using
the computer so much and and contacting
people and being in touch with families
and doing zoom calls and God knows what
else ya know I've my hands when I were
just talking with that I'm like I have
never felt busier and I already was
really busy so because it's now it's all
the jobs like plus taking care of the
children and cooking and clean all this
stuff that I don't know all of it so
Kelly we've been together for about
eight years we've been married
yeah he's good but we're you know there
have been points in this pandemic where
I'm like you need to go and he he feels
the same so it's a lot of togetherness
time with three we have four children
but three are in our house with us right
now because I know my 18 so but but
enough about me no one cares about me to
care about you
so no dude I'm interest
you should be you're way cooler so my
point though is I know that you will not
remember this because it is like a
non-event for you but just so you know
obviously the Princess Diaries you're in
and I was the single from the movie the
song was called break win so they
invited me to that premiere years ago
and you don't know this but I was I
never say hi to people generally because
I get too nervous but article was my
dress it was a green dress with flowers
and it grazed your clothes as we passed
on the red carpet I'm so mad
what you think it's so silly but it made
my entire like I talked about it for a
year I was like I was legit inches from
doing it Kelly didn't you send me
something once you sent you recording of
yours or something yeah it was because I
had a Christmas record coming out and I
was hanging out with Trisha Yearwood and
her publicist is it you do have the same
publicist or something that was worth
and I think it's the same agent I'm not
sure that's what it was it was somebody
she was at the house and she was like oh
yeah I work with jewel and as I was like
wait what and I was like oh my god I
just covered my favorite things that
it's it's completely different it's a
different kind of version like romantic
send it to me I think yeah
she said she was like well I'll send it
to her and I was like oh my god I think
I did it was really lovely oh thank you
so much thank you so much I try some
days I sound you know nice and some days
I sound like Janis Joplin because I'm
tired but whatever but it's been
separating people but also uniting them
and I I heard that you had said
something interesting and you said it
reminded you of World War two a little
bit haha so obviously young child during
the war and it was that fear of the
unknown that lack of control that you
have little bit like when you're in an
earthquake or something there's nothing
you can do you don't know when it's
gonna happen but but the war made
everyone in England where I was born
with
like crazy because we absolutely had to
support each other and be strong for
each other and try to be brave and calm
and so on and it's very much the same
way now with this huge pandemic um
everybody's terrified and worried and
scared it's very similar so for me it
brings back those memories a little bit
I didn't randomly I did this interview
in the UK a while back while promoting a
record and Vanessa redgraves is there
promoting a project she was doing and
she actually talked about that in the
interview oh it's a Sara Lee was you
know it was huge for those of us who
were well if it had been you wonderful
Americans we probably not be here today
but who came in to help rescue and do
wonderful things for us but my parents
and I was in Waterville in musical and
we went to an American army base and our
salary was a good party meal and I was
given a t-bone steak which I'd never
seen in my life but I've never seen so
much meat in my life that entire t-bone
would have had our family during the
rationing four of us five of us you know
it was wonderful suffering so seeing the
way the I guess it was all Mia I think I
don't think it was a force but whatever
it was it was an amazing visit it really
was and I had to entertain oh my god but
they freaked out that's so cool that's
so cool and you were give said you were
younger right oh yeah I was very young
yes but it was well I started singing
when I was about seven or eight so yeah
and then the war ended when I was about
10 I guess so Wow
so what exactly is the podcast tell us
about it oh it's just called Julie's
library and it's about I and my daughter
are in my little library and we read
books or it's really geared toward very
young children but hopefully their
parents
and round here is even who were going to
sit with them and listen and after we've
read the story we discuss it we talk
about the ideas we talk about words and
how wonderful they are and we invite the
kids to send things to us and they come
online and all kinds of things and it's
some hopefully comforting and something
to listen to and spark the imagination a
little bit so it was silly not to try to
get it ready for release and that's what
we did no I'm from one parent to another
thank you um but while we're talking
with the podcast I do want to obviously
bring in Emma your daughter let's let's
bring Emma in Emma can you hear us you
hear
I can can you hear me I can meet you
alright we were just talking about the
podcast Julie screaming that's what
you're calling it right it's library but
you know theorem is something that I'd
love to talk about as well because so
Julie's green room is a Netflix series
that we did about four years ago
together and it stars mom as the
director of her own small theatre
company and she has students who come
and learn theatre how to produce a
musical basically from her and those
were puppets created by the Jim Henson
Company
it's a lovely show that celebrates the
Arts and we've been finding and hearing
that people have been discovering it
again during quarantine and so like Sun
balm has embarked on a social media
campaign of putting out some little
videos in conjunction with each of the
episodes on Facebook and also we have
wonderful guest stars just grow but we
haven't is and lots of fun people that's
amazing y'all also a night I know this
because whenever I was actually writing
my own children's book I was in there
and witnessed starting to kind of look
at all these stories and I was like I
have no idea but y'all y'all had written
what is it thirty books together
children's books especially over thirty
now I think it's thirty
yeah a lot of work I mean because
honestly I've written a couple in there
they're almost harder like the cadence
and how I because my rhyme as well so
it's just like the cadence of it is it's
kind of goofy you it's it's very
difficult oh thank you but it was um it
was just a really interesting thing like
how does that work like whatever you'll
have like because even me with my editor
and we have creative differences like
how does that work between you two like
who wins in that creative argument the
best idea wins the deal is that's our
saying yeah if we have if we stumble on
something there are two or three things
that work but what is for sure our
mantra is that the best idea wins if one
of us is more passionate about something
else permanently believed that this is
the way to go and so on we one of us the
other one seems to recognize that and
then the other is to take a little break
for a cup of tea or even a bottle break
once in a while and it does wonders for
the brain because you suddenly stop what
you're doing and while you're fiddling
around with a cup of tea or something
you get back on track somehow any better
way to say that it can you the answer
comes yeah the answer does it's because
you free the brain for a moment yeah I
know I even writing songs I'm like that
I have to walk away and come back and
kind of escape the bubble but my
question though is I grew up around so
many books and that's why I'm an avid
reader now god bless my mom I'm glad
that she instilled that in me um but my
favorite book I can't ever escape and
I'm really getting into it now with my
five-year-old little girl who now is in
love with it as well but was Matilda
that was my favorite uh it was my first
like big book to read by myself and I
was wondering since other authors I mean
any love reading as well like what would
you suggest like what were your favorite
books when you were kids like what's a
story that you really love do you think
parents should maybe get and read with
them you know so we actually finish
each other sentences so that's funny
though my daughter never liked y'all
anyway we do see each other sensors
going at him alright so for me that look
was the Phantom Tollbooth I was such a
that was my rainy-day book my go-to book
and I just loved the idea of like being
in your own house and getting in as a
toy car and driving through a little toy
Tollbooth of being in a totally
different world and what I loved best
was that in that book one of the places
he drove to was a town called diction
appleís where people literally bought
and sold words and words had like
flavors and colors to them and I was
just so completely enchanted by that and
I think that's part of the reason why I
love words to this day I really do and
you know is that the podcast that Yellin
ball with the words right with you as
kids their favorite words and thank you
personally I cool that y'all are
innovative with that in you and you
include them and you're engaging them
that's a really really clever thing to
do what do you lose to to know my kids
Michael my daughter's learning to read
right now so she loves like anytime she
gets a new word she feel so proud so
what what are some of your favorite
words if you love words so much Emma
what are some of your favorite ones
family yes definitely one we actually we
sort of have started to play a game
recently
believe it or not because this is sad
and terrible time and I was trying to
say to the family because we get on
zoom' all of us you know I've got
children in California and I've got
relatives and family in England and so
on so I was saying to them all think of
the nicest word you can think of to
cheer us all today and we'll each
contribute and my word I think the first
one I came up with was spring I think
another favorite of mine is is hope and
it's not just because it's a beautiful
word for right now but it's also my
daughter's name and I think that's why I
chose it why we chose it yeah I hope in
Sam right that's right those great names
they are great fact in fact County Santa
City
right in front of me today because he's
a phenomenal sound engineer and he's
been helping me get on to this recording
today because I know nothing about it
and I'm gonna play the game
what am I think my people possibly my
favorite word is magic oh yeah not just
because it's escapism I like the magic
of it and and and you know the word that
word but I like that anything can be
magical like you know a moment like as
snow you know it could be snowing
outside or it could be something your
kid says to you the kind of brick sure
yeah well honestly there are so many if
you stop thinking about them wonder
wonder is another favorite of ours yeah
we have a motto for our publishing
company which is words wisdom wonder
words lead to wisdom which lead to
wonder and mastery w's I love that I
love you all as a team you're so great
it's a great great pleasure I mean we
didn't know and we began writing
together that it would be such a joy but
I mean can you imagine at Kelly's your
little girl five grew up and became an
equal and beloved equal and you were
writing with it so it's quite a
wonderful gift and that's the way it was
when you were young in it we didn't yeah
yeah I think that connection nothing
beats it when you have something that
your kid like even like my kid like no
one in my family this is gonna sound
ridiculous no one in my family likes
beets
but I love beets and so my daughter came
along and like she's the one that she's
like obsessed with beets with me sweet
all the time and as we say in my family
you share the beets gene right yes I
know you either hate him or love them
yeah subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going